nouveau coup dur pour l'ex-star de télé
réalité loana alors qu'elle était venu
nous donner de ses nouvelles en
exclusivité le 9 février dernier sur
notre plateau merci d'être là
merci beaucoup loana et qu'elle nous
avait annoncé après ses multiples des
pressions et tentatives de suicides
vouloir enfin reprendre sa vie en main
carmina je crois que loana aurait été
transporté à l'hôpital de hyères dans
l'après midi après une énième overdose
pourtant hier elle s'affichait heureuse
à cannes au bras de nicolas son ange
gardien comme elle aime l'appeler mais
quel est l'état de santé actuel de loana
que s'est il vraiment passé
les réponses tout de suite sur notre
plateau alors on a eu un communiqué bien
il y a un instant on a vu dans que loana
hospitalisés d'après star magazine
aurait composé consommer une dose une
dose massive de ghb est serein
consciente depuis plusieurs heures
lorsque c'est vrai cette affaire oui en
fait avant exceptionnels bien sûr on est
en train de tourner ce documentaire avec
loana tout se passe bien pendant les
journées de tournage on est dans le sud
de la france actuellement la journée ça
se passe très bien on a pu voir sur les
images là vous voyez des photos et les
elle est plutôt jovial et agréable à
travailler le soir en fait c'est une
autre histoire
hier soir en fait lohan a été
raccompagné à son hôtel par son
chauffeur pascal un chauffeur à
disposition à les entourer un sur ce
tournage évidemment on la laisse pas
seul malheureusement la nuit elle est
dans sa chambre et ce matin guillaume
garnier qui est notre rédacteur en chef
a retrouvé loana dans un état lamentable
dans sa chambre avec la chambre sans
dessus dessous les poubelles qui ont été
fouillés
donc elle a été emmenée aux urgences à 9
heures du matin elle est à l'hôpital
d'hyères
elle était dans un état très grave mais
elle peut encore elle peut encore parler
et elle va être transférée en hôpital
psychiatrique
voilà sur la consommation 10 est passé à
l' alors nous l'avait dit elle a arrêté
donc à la loi dadt ne s'en cache pas
elle a pris de la drogue elle a pris de
la cocaïne à un règlement avec moi là
elle a arrêté la cocaïne
en revanche ce qu'on a vu sur le
tournage c'est qu'elle était tout le
temps avec une bouteille d'un d'une
célèbre boisson et on s'est rendu compte
que dès qu'elle n'en buvaient en fait
elle changé d'état et et elle aurait une
boisson alcoolisée de boisset d'oasis
voilà une boisson voilà elle aurait mis
dans cette bouteille du gic
non mais non mais l'abus de mélanger un
oui mélangé avec du ghb liquide qui est
le ghb qui est comme la drogue des
violeurs c'est une drogue
quand vous prenez cette drogue vous
pouvez être violées ne pas vous en
souvenir donc c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement puissant extrêmement
dangereux et elle aurait pris cette
substance est mis en fait elle aurait
en cette bouteille aurait été jeté à la
poubelle ce qui explique le fait qu'elle
a retourné sa chambre et que les
poubelles -enfin la chambre était sens
dessus dessous
voilà et je répète que tout se passait
bien pendant le pendant pendant pendant
le tournage ont nagé des images des
dernières images de loana qu'on a tourné
juste avant l'incident m6 en fait juste
après sa victoire du locle lui avait
prêté une villa pendant deux mois on est
retourné sur les lieux de cette vie là
il était alors dans la séquence
ces images demain c'est vrai que merci
en tout cas quand j'entends nous donner
des infos demain vous n'aura d'autre
d'infos sur le rhône à puisque c'est
guillaume qui réalise le documentaire
sur elle-même